in other videos we have talked about how
a vector can be completely defined by a
magnitude and a direction you need both
and here we have done that we have said
that the magnitude of vector a is equal
to three units these parallel lines here
on both sides it looks like a double
absolute value that means the magnitude
of vector a and you could also specify
that visually by making sure that the
length of this vector arrow is 3 units
long and we also have its direction we
see the direction of vector a is 30
degrees counterclockwise
of do east
now in this video we're going to talk
about other ways or another way to
specify or to define a vector and that's
by using
components
and the way that we're going to do it is
we're going to think about the tail of
this vector and the head of this vector
and think about as we go from the tail
to the head what is our change in x
and we could see our change in x would
be
that right over there we're going from
this x value to this x value and then
what is going to be our change in y and
if we're going from down here to up here
our change in y we can also specify
like
that so let me label these this is my
change in x and then this is my change
in y and if you think about it if
someone told you your change in x and
change in y you could reconstruct this
vector right over here by starting here
having that change in x then having the
change in y and then defining where the
tip of the vector would be relative to
the tail the notation for this is we
would say that vector a
is equal to
and we'll have parentheses and we'll
have our change in x comma change in y
and so if we wanted to get tangible for
this particular vector right over here
we know the length of this vector is 3
its magnitude is 3.
we know that this is since this is going
due horizontally and then this is going
straight up and down this is a right
triangle
and so we can use a little bit of
geometry from the past don't worry if
you need a little bit of a refresher on
this but we could use a little bit of
geometry or a little bit of trigonometry
to establish if we know this angle if we
know the length of this hypotenuse
that
this side that's opposite the 30 degree
angle is going to be half the hypotenuse
so it's going to be three halves and
that the change in x is going to be the
square root of 3 times the 3 halves so
it's going to be 3 square roots of 3
over 2. and so up here we would write
our x component is 3 times the square
root of 3 over 2 and we would write that
the y component is 3 halves now i know a
lot of you might be thinking this looks
a lot like coordinates in the coordinate
plane where this would be the x
coordinate and this would be the y
coordinate but when you're dealing with
vectors that's not exactly the
interpretation it is the case that if
the vector's tail were at the origin
right over here then its head would be
at these coordinates on the coordinate
plane
but we know that a vector is not defined
by its position by the position of the
tail i could shift this vector around
wherever and it would still be the same
vector it can start wherever so when you
use this notation in a vector context
these aren't x coordinates and y
coordinates this is our change in x and
this is our change in y
let me do one more example to show that
we can actually go the other way
so let's say i defined some vector
b
and let's say
that its x component is square root of 2
and let's say that its y component is
square root of 2.
so let's think about what that vector
would look like so it would if this is
its tail
and its x component which is its change
in x is square root of 2 so it might
look something like this
so that would be
change in x is equal to square root of
two
and then its y component would also be
square root of two
so i could write
our change in y over here is square root
of two and so the vector would look
something like this it would start here
and then it would go
over
here
and we can use a little bit of geometry
to figure out the magnitude and the
direction of this vector you can use the
pythagorean theorem to establish that
this squared plus this square is going
to be equal to that squared and if you
do that you're going to get this having
a length of 2 which tells you that the
magnitude of vector b
is equal to 2. and if you wanted to
figure out this angle right over here
you could do a little bit of
trigonometry or even a little bit of
geometry recognizing that this is going
to be a right angle right over here and
that this side and that side have the
same length so these are going to be the
same angles which are going to be 45
degree angles and so just like that you
could also specify the direction 45
degrees counterclockwise of do east so
hopefully you appreciate that these are
equivalent ways of representing a vector
you either can have a magnitude in a
direction or you can have your
components and you can go back and forth
between the two and we'll get more
practice of that in future videos